أريد حقًا وفقًا للتقاليد الروسية ووفقًا لـ
تقاليد الأرض المقدسة لبيرة داغستان
معكم اليوم نرفع هذا
الزجاج والشراب لذكرى الذين ماتوا
أنا حقا أريدك أن تكون ملكنا وجرحا و
أتمنى السعادة لكل من هو هنا
نكون
ولكن لدينا الكثير من المشاكل التي تنتظرنا و
المهام الكبيرة التي تعرفها جيدًا
أنت تعرف ما نخطط ضده ونحن
معك أيضا يعرف ما هي الاستفزازات
من المتوقع في المستقبل القريب
المناطق ، أنا وأنت لا نملك الحق
لا تسمح لثانية بضعف إيزيس و
الثانية لأننا إذا فعلنا ذلك
ثم من مات
عندما اتضح أنه ليس كل شخص
منع لذلك أقترح
لإعادته اليوم
وجوب وجوب الذروة
سيكون في وقت لاحق
ثم عند هذه المهمة
حملة حرا في الأساس ستكون كل العلامات
تم الحل
لذلك أقترح الآن بطريقة مسيرة
نقل وكسب